citizens of the reject Nation I want to
thank all of you guys who have been
joining us for the Ahsoka reactions and
now we're here for the Ahsoka finale but
more importantly I want to thank
everyone who bought this shirt the real
Rex exclusive one that just came in the
mail for him w got it just in time baby
real reject exclusive Ahsoka snip snip
lightsaber scissors you get it that's
what I'm talking about and of course
real reject has other exclusive Star
Wars related type of shirts as well we
got our Pedro Pascal from last of us
carrying grou our child protection
services shirt of course we got our aoda
t-shirt and then you know our classic
space babies and we got other shirts as
well like our who influences The
influencers Watchman inspired tea and
then we got a whole bunch more it is one
of the absolute best ways to support the
channel September was our most
successful month thank you guys so much
for supporting the channel helps pay for
people like Michael Tesla or Star Wars
offici UT to beer how are you Michael
you excited I'm paid that's great news
you at the end of the year I'm so
excited are you excited I am a so
excited John who yeah I've Sabine
waiting for this use the force to leave
a like ladies and gentlemen as always
full length Reaction watch along this
where you sync up with your own copy of
Ahsoka available for our super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page thank
you to all who have joined us for the
journey for Ahsoka over there but we
also cover several things exclusively
with reaction highlights and watch along
included let's see what this episode is
all about and if it sticks The
Landing let's go please be great please
be
great Kevin CER Music Man keeps killing
it ever since he got fired off
Yellowstone once again kudos to the VFX
team they have a fix on the Jed sh
location dispatch two Tie fighters if
they find their Mark tell them to engage
and find me a tailor I need to bring are
old timey and outdated there is little
the Jedi can do to stop us now even I
fell victim to the heroics of a single
Jedi Star Wars
Rebels references they had to be there
we are grateful to you Grand
Admiral and to you Morgan
elth all she wanted was to be
appreciated dude it's your time is she
going to get what she wants or is she
about to get the axe you shall be
rewarded with sacrifice the gift of
Shadows gift of Shadows I'm so excited
to see this
who whoa eight yes oh wow sweet yes
sweet
welcome
whoa those
eyes sound some freaky
today I know a thr does not like any of
this man he really kills it with the
music blade
yes the
blade eat it up Morgan take it take it
sister sister all right that's
sick go forth and kick an ass oh wow
great upgrade from a best our
spear that's a big uh got a feeling that
uh grou and Company are going to see
that one
day that's great shot great shot all
right there's a prologue for you I think
it's going to be
okay three and a half out of
five Jedi the witch in The Warlord nice
flying the witch in The
Wardrobe it's just like such a funny
thing to do with the title I love it the
thonic of death Amir thonic no no that's
not going to work look not going to work
what are you talking about the blade
emitter is too narrow even this set
looks were colorful even though we've
seen this set before stop that
everything in here is organized yeah
disorganized I have a system this will
be his third lightsaber I have a system
who taught you how to build a lightsaber
anyway Kanan jerus hell yeah Caleb D and
I taught him how to build a lightsaber
of course now it all makes
sense
how could you know him I taught almost
every youngling at the Jedi Temple when
he was Caleb boy Caleb was very curious
how old are you old enough to know that
the relationship between a master and an
apprentice is as challenging as it is
Meaningful amen old enough for True
wisdom my guy faid tenant really knocked
it out of the park dror huyang is
killing it yeah that's it I had two of
them Kanan took the one the other I held
on to in case he ever needed it oh
that's great oh that's a amazing thank
you
H it's
red it's the deepest red everyone who
was complaining last episode sted it
looks like you were a good
student unlike some students Bean ahoka
ever teach you how to oh get back here
Ahsoka became afraid that Sabine was
training as a Jedi for the wrong reasons
after what happened on mandelo oh boy
killing hundreds of thousands her family
were all lost sadly oh man aera felt
that if Sabine unlocked her potential
she would become
dangerous give to the dark side your
gamble paid off so you know I
do it's okay I'm white now I'm chill
about this
stuff they stand side by side
sorry know
I
know is that a reference to something
that was a joke internet can't imagine
what it could be made my share of
difficult choices no one understood my
reasons except my
master I love whenever you talk about
Anakin talk Anakin to me he
always stood by me even when no one else
did now you must do the same for Sabine
no matter what happens
next I'm going to be there for you I
hope you don't regret those words
now a smile have you kept up with your
training I
try there's no trying I
do being a
Jedi isn't about wielding a lightsaber
what it helps especially in our
situation train your mind train your
body work harder on yourself
trust and the force and go to therapy
VIs visualize dream board see that's why
it was okay that Ezra didn't use a
lightsaber last episode
guys could really use the
[Laughter]
lightsaber me
now oh all
right we've lost the
stabilizer
oh
wow
man imagine the send of the two of them
just getting
crushed we held on as long as we
could these guys are so
[Music]
Eerie fly right into him
boom same combo naughty looks right
right at the camera oh
boy well that's that's a
problem not a
scratch he like I've had the ship for
years got
him oh these poor
guys poor shell gang this is going to
slow us down a bit
only if we let it h i love ahsoka's K do
attitude the successful strike on the
Jedi shuttle was reported before we lost
contact with the flight group an
acceptable
outcome I think he is perfect that he's
still giving citations even in this we
should prepare for a ground
assault
good immediately better more action
yes lead them Gandalf
[Music]
yeah we need some giant eagles in here
next a be with you and also with you
lift up your sa and with your spirit
look at that it's a classic Western shot
right there the blessing of the great
mothers shall protect you in battle
against the Jedi I cannot wait for thraw
and Ahsoka to finally meet face to face
and for Ahsoka to fight all will honor
to make the sacrifice for the Empire the
security of our galaxy the security of
our galaxy that's an important line cuz
there is a greater threat how's it
going you've kept her in this guy longer
than I've been
alive yes I'll be so upset if who Yang's
Left Behind thrawn found this place woke
up the witches rebuilt his Starship woke
up the witches well you're not alone
anymore let's try the front
door R right up to the Fortress walls
that's interesting so we specifically
sought this place out there's something
larger at play rain Hellfire upon them
there been no negotiating with The
Apprentice of Anakin Skywalker sick he
feels the
threat this is seriously the Lord of the
Rings wow oh my God Jesus D
BL rain hell from
above Death from
Above I mean it's nice to know that even
the Star Destroyers don't know how to
shoot
straight whoever designs the weapons for
them Sabine help out come on
Sabine this feels like a Star Wars video
game that's exactly what it feels
like
oo
yes oh jez that was
uncomfortable pull together thr hold
together dispatch the night
triers and bring me my brown uniform I
think there might be some
Undead elements perhaps a this is sick
interesting that we just cut to this I
know fall back draw them
out do like the shot of the three
lightsabers saine
Blaster General
Ahsoka there we go Ezra with a
lightsaber oh man come
on baby
oh
boom that was a baby great shot that's
still her show still her show nice she
was so it was so calm a so
calm oh
boy yes come on oh it's it's going to
happen they going to resurrect yes I so
Hing necromancy so hoping for this this
this has been the dream of Star Wars
fans for a long time yes nice theories
confirmed I was going to say like it was
it was sudden how like just Victorious
and easy going that was yeah yeah they
know the regular Troopers ain't
this ever happened before no this is new
lucky
us we'll just keep taking them down they
still suck at shooting yes yeah now
they're probably a little worse that
they even move like
zombies o oh man for Halloween
season
God they are like a hoorde aren't
they force push them away and they have
less
fear some of them are even trying to use
their guns God just the growls the eyes
the microphones
yeah he's going to bite you you're going
to
turn careful careful
oh
yeah
nice oh go good job with the lightsaber
a training paying off uhoh thank God all
doors closed when you hit them see the
default nice moves she's been training
what's your excuse I missed you a like
sci-fi doors are always programmed to do
the opposite when you destroy them if
they're closed they open if they're open
they closed we are ready to depart
grandad
yeah they make it on board the ship we
require a little more
time you got to stay behind and fight I
understand is that what's happening she
seems committed for the
Empire this this dude's playing all
[Music]
along you were just used as a backup
plan good luck
wow I actually feel kind of bad for her
right traveled to the other
Galaxy man Justice for Morgan El Beth no
she's she's done uh everything she
promised I'm excited for the rematch
with Ahsoka we need you to have a boss
battle there we go I was going to say
man this is way too short of a
threat that seems like a Sabine and Ezra
problem while ahoka gets the
rematch it's cool that we're in like a
castle Siege
now like the king arthan
Vibes go on I'll handle this let's see
what happens you must stop
throwing she was a formidable opponent
she was this is the way and now she's
got some
powers
oh yeah
sick oh I love the sound
[Music]
design a love the overhead shot
too okay this is a good looking fight
yeah this is a day floting type fight oh
my
gosh whoa oh
yeah that was well done man
oh it got chills from that fight add
some new things to the Lucas Sound
Library The ilm Sound
Library oh
yeah
Best Care ouch God these guys
punches finally got that trailer shot
yeah I'm having fun with the episode but
I am a feeling of lack of tension at the
same time sure but at the same time I
don't know where we're going take us out
maybe we're going
going oh
boy oh my God are they going to actually
get separated from
huyang I like a lot of these action
visual shots
though whoa show it sick pull the helmet
off Force push them do the thing you
were
doing come it's time Focus life for
death just jiggle it a little bit I'll
be happy with that yeah oh look at that
mouth don't be a fake out hey as it
Ezra see
kylo well done
sned
oh that trailer reaction oh I got so
much crap for say she was force
sensitive
Vindicated but can she Force jump
doesn't matter let her fall to her
[Music]
death I think this is a very well
choreographed fight I 100% agree
uh-oh not so tough without your
[Music]
goons oh okay yeah the cacophony of all
this stuff stacking on top of her is
good that's just some uh Order 66
flashbacks for
her we can't hit that all right who
yangang you can't make that jump yes you
can oh she can't give him Force push you
first and you pull me
across whoa and that's teamwork I can do
this what you can do is call up on the
space bu imagine traveling to a
different galaxy only to accidentally
kill
azra the longer you hesitate the harder
get come
on
okay
go no for
thing damn sa
nice oh oh
Jesus that's all red who you he it's a
thick platform
okay baby
baby it's great shot come on your turn
Ahsoka did you see me I can't leave her
is Ahsoka actually going to get stranded
she got hyang she still got hyang and
Balin oh my
God a this
is there's a lot oh
no everyone stop shooting yeah this is
too good to miss
yeah sh wow wow wow wow gain your
composure you guys are going to have to
learn to get along you will die
here alone no alone not
alone oh hell yeah hey
hey my
man I'm really proud of her I know
right
and it's full circle it's nice wow she
is found her balance she knows Ezra's
okay she come back for
Ahsoka where the hell is Balin oh yeah
maybe they already set up the
[Music]
movie
oh oh wow oh I didn't actually want her
to die I know I
really a
same she was just like
o well she has done what was
required Justice for morg than L's back
like how you see thraw being like keep
it together keep it together 757 here
ass this is
Jaa this Lando Cal that little boy game
on his oh my God he's literally doing it
where's AZ he going home oh are they
going to get left behind I'm right
behind
you hey a Mandalorian Jedi have the main
batteries Target The Fortress for
bombardment affirmative Grand Admiral
but that's that's our
home wow SI shot yeah not their shots
though
yes
hey Back to the Future to the
Future later butt heads Ahsoka I used
the force did you see my training look
it all comes crumbling
down man thron's going to be real grumpy
about this can we catch him I am
diverting all power to the engines oh
feeling this suspense it's back it's
back people
I just I don't genuinely know if we're
going to get there I love it I love
these shots so
much come on make the ship that thing is
H make the
ship allow me to commend you on your
efforts today they meet I regret we
haven't met face to face and perhaps now
we never
shall God Dam it come on I know
you because I knew your
Master oh she's going to oh
no one wonders just how similar you
might
become a confirmation he knows this
is where a ronin such as sh belongs
Ronin a sonin today victory is mine so
close oh he's taunting long live the
Empire
no no yeah
oh
sheeps oh my
God o could to make you feel the force
against you don't worry guys we'll get
season two in like three
years very satisfying
followup
well Ezra can hijack the ship and go
back yes all by himself you know there's
kind of poetry to him going with
[Music]
thrawn we are the new
ezas we are your new human overlords
guess this explains where Ahsoka was
during the rise of the first order and
but what about
Ezra
Morse wait a second
morai I wonder if there's another way
back speaking of that's the first time
we saw it like like an actual live
action right yeah I think
[Music]
so oh oh she found her
people I guess this is where her Destiny
called her to wow super Lord of the
Rings oh my God that looks a lot like
the father right that that's his beard
right oh a total oh my
god wow oh my God
it's exactly oh it's so he found it's
the
mother gleaming beacon the the exiled
mother is that's right cuz there's only
father daughter and son and she was
exiled and daughters with Ahsoka oh my
God you're right yeah look at that shot
which might make Balin the Sun
that's huge that's really big and
they're going straight to
damir and they're going to start
resurrecting bring me
Maul very Spiel bergy they're Wheeling
the ark down there just now damn that's
a big ass ending reveal of Balin for his
One Moment In the episode too is that
asra is he going to get reunited yes
hey how was zra I pretend to be on the
dark
[Laughter]
side uh maybe helmet off
first dramatic effect is great
but it's Chopper trying to say Chopper
no Chopper trying to say how how can
Chopper tell it's Chopper it's for
sensitive hey
[Music]
buddy
vinra and I know the perfect Padawan for
him oh yeah hi
Hara I'm
home yeah you
are don't worry about a so will be
yes at least they know where to go to
get them yeah well how the heck do you
get
there got to find some more
perill if there's one person who can do
it it's almost like Ahsoka needed to
come here to fulfill the mortis Ark it
makes sense it all comes back to that
even when we first discovered World
Between Worlds you know thanks to you
Ezra got
home do you have confirmation of that
just not here I
hope look at that pragmatist Ezra is
where he needs to
be and so are we oh man dude you get so
in tune with the force here it's time to
move
on they're both going to have big beards
by the next
season what is
it I felt like a disturbance in the
forest something
familiar nothing no say it just shadows
in a
Starlight bars shadows in the
Starlight
Anakin I think so Force goost
Anakin muasa Cloud Anakin
please
I would love if they pan up to an Anakin
shaped constellation just winking one
eye
yes
dude do not look happy no no he's
he's wow he looks even better than he
did in the Return of the Jedi special
edition that a rick F ricka look at that
oh wow that was fun I am I am satisfied
I started off in a way where I was like
I'm enjoying it Uh something's kind of
like missing in suspense and then the
last half I really thought really
brought it man and then some big things
to talk about we got some we got some
things to talk about we're getting an
Ezra Bridger show and Jace I just what a
great pairing and a perfect master I
know to go from Kanan to Ezra from Ezra
to Jace that'd be awesome it also would
be great if we keep them separate from
Luke so they don't all get slaughtered
by KY all righty guys well we got some
talking points to hit here we got things
we got to go over um if you are
listening to this on Apple or Spotify uh
please rate this video that we just
watched Ahsoka finale um oh no we got to
do our generals out of the way generals
um John what would you rate it out of 10
uh eight I give this one a solid eight
that was pretty good that was pretty
thrilling what would you give it I would
give it a general Kenobi come on what's
that honestly honestly I'm just
impressed I'm impressed that they got as
much done they it's a nine wow it's a
nine it's a nine Disney shill over here
Disney shill yeah easy to Disney do me a
favor if if I'm gonna be such a shill
pay me
already I've racked up a lot of credit I
would argue no I mean I've given this
series I think some Fair criticisms over
the course but I think this was a tough
finale and I think they wrapped it up in
a way that I'm satisfied excited and I
have questions but I also got answers
yeah how about you
Greg four out of 10 okay this about Fair
yeah yeah really want to balance the
scales I agree I'm balanced four Bal I
got to edit so I'm gonna delay this even
more to make life more stressful for
me no I would uh i' would actually meet
John at an eight actually yeah I'm I'm
about an eight I have some criticisms
about the episode uh but over all no um
there's a lot that I really like I
probably bump it up to like an 8.1.7
five by the time that
we're Nott way to go I'll probably go
down to an eight by the time I'm done
talking if this was Rotten Tomatoes I'd
be like
83% yeah sure yeah yeah yeah all right
then um so okay uh John please since you
are the lowest of us yes since I am what
are your general thoughts we'll call
this chapter John's General thoughts
John's uh no I liked this
episode I thought yeah yeah I was having
certain reservations similar to yours
earlier on being like okay you know this
is thrilling and immediate but is this
going to be as satisfying as like a
season finale needs to be and this isn't
necessarily like the big allout
punctuation you know that you might
expect from a a series fin a season
finale but you know the pace of the
series up until now has kind of led me
to expect something that felt and you
know was scaled a bit more like this is
clearly part of an ongoing story that
will probably span out as you guys have
speculated past Ahsoka into other
spin-offs and whatnot that all said uh I
thought the developments with like
seeing the night sisters do their thing
and the night uh Troopers and all that
stuff like that scratches itches for me
just as like a witchcraft love and
horror person but beyond that I thought
this made for a an appropriately
thrilling immediate and you know
palpable uh end chapter and by the time
we get to those finale moments of like
them doing the alley push of Ezra on to
the ship and Morgan El's best's fight
with Ahsoka and you know them making the
sacrifice to at least get one of them
home the person we came here for home
all those things coales to be pretty
satisfying to me in the end and then the
stuff setting up for the future
especially with like even though I have
no idea kind of what you guys are
talking about when it comes to what
Balin is looking for like the
amalgamation of his presence up till now
plus the Striking he think he can do it
better than the Nazis yes so he's
looking for the dial of Destiny to go
back he needs to go back so that he can
kill Hitler and then take place it's not
on Disney
plus no no no no no it's okay it's not
that's not what it's about but but uh
ask okay Michael but even that stuff got
me very intrigued like I was like oh I
cannot wait to find out or or at least
I'm very excited to find out what uh the
next step of his journey will be tragedy
of his loss as an actor as side all that
stuff you know piqu my interest in this
did all the things I think a finale is
supposed to do to you so yeah sure yeah
I dug it yeah man all right here's my
general thoughts really quick my general
thoughts are from the following several
months ago did a trailer reaction of
sooka and there were many comments many
many comments and I'm just going to read
the top comment won't say the name
because I confidently said not even
questionably or apprehensively said
Sabine is force sensitive oh and the top
comment was saine is not force sensitive
one of the top comments s's not force
sensitive she's one of the few non-force
sensitive people to wield a lightsaber
and then goes on to explain stuff
basically but it's a whole bunch of back
and forth in the comments 67 replies
about how she's not force
sensitive and I would have been part of
that camp I was like no she is that's
that's 67 plates of crow we got to serve
up now boom this episode went to a 10
out of 10 for me just who's sensitive
[Laughter]
now see that ego stroking it yeah stroke
that ego like a lightsaber stroke that
everybody like a
lightsaber uh you stoke to lightsaber it
would cut it would melt your hand I I i'
actually what about Morgan Elis i' I'd
actually agree I know she was talking on
the side it was interesting uh I'd
actually agree with wasen a lightsaber
I'd agree with with everything you you
said John actually if you want to know
my general thoughts skip to John's
General thoughts and then go Greg sounds
like those are Greg's General thoughts
are are we putting them on an infinite
Loop of just rewatching that segment but
I'm just I guess I'm more ex I really
like the F I'll just add to like I
really like the fight choreography quite
a bit um like just to add on a couple of
other things you were saying like yeah
some of that tension was a little bit
missing for me when you know like they
they go into like it's it was fun I
wouldn't say thrilling it was fun and
then they go into the temple then just
like Cuts two and they're just fighting
the night Troopers I was like something
feels off about the editing here like
what are they trying to sell me on and
while I like the gracefulness of Ahsoka
fighting there was also something where
I felt like she wasn't really playing to
anything physical like I could feel like
the Detachment of green screen and stuff
so that was some of the things that was
kind of like uh undercutting it for me
when necromancy night Trooper thing
happened I thought that was really U I
thought that was really fun that was
really cool and then that's when the
suspense and ex and and intrig started
really build for me and I really did
love the last half of this and I thought
the Morgan Elizabeth fight uh with
Ahsoka I thought the choreography was
great I love when they do you got like
multip people lightsabers and blades and
whatnot and what I think is really
impressive is when you can demonstrate
the different types of fight
choreography style while putting it in
one fight you know because they're
they're very distinct fighting styles
and I thought like towards the end I was
really gripped and I loved everything
they set up like the T I did not I
thought it was going to be something
more Zeo related you've been going more
chis route which is still there still
there oh yeah I I'm holding firm on that
um and you think with what this planet
has in store that uh that that because
it's like I think Thon we'll talk more
about it but something I thought was
interesting like Thon is constantly you
know downplaying the Jedi but from being
on this planet you think he but but I
think I think he does I don't think he
ever necessarily downplay the right
that's not the right call downplaying he
talks down to the J about the Jedi uh
but no he definitely doesn't down
downplay would mean he doesn't find the
threat but he was clar like no we got to
eliminate these guys I agree with that
but I feel like his mentality is very
similar to like you know in in episode
four when all the Imperial officers are
talking to Vader about like you know
your wacky your wacky order you know and
I think it's a
similar they fought a a a worthless
Crusade and you know he looks down on
them because they were so easily
manipulated but but but um Mel dude yeah
um um as as as somebody that like loved
the expanded universe growing up in
playing all the games reading bunch of
the comics reading the books this was
like the nicest Love Letter uh in so
many ways like and and they did it in a
way that did feel inauthentic in a way
that didn't feel unearned which I
honestly think is the most impressive
part about this finale like did it give
me everything I wanted no but everything
that we did get I felt like we deserved
it based on everything that's happened
development character growth even Sabine
like they could have gone overboard and
I think what they did with being able to
grab the lightsaber and do the push it
was it was exactly about as far as I
feel that she deserved to get uh in
terms of of the force um and it was I
think it's impressive up until the end I
I really I didn't know who's going to
land where um and I think in a in an age
of like such predictability
it was so nice to genuinely be like oh
wow that's that's a surprising twist
that has completely like any like
pre-existing theories that people have
or like Investments of of time into uh
into where they thought this was going
has now been thrown off course yet again
yeah um and I'm genuinely excited and
intrigued by all the seeds that were
planted uh that being said like the
action
sequences like they were they were fun I
had a lot of fun and and um talk about
the ones Michael the ones talk about the
ones so we call this chapter the ones
the ones so you know for for those that
watch the Clone Wars uh like we know the
mortise Arc uh and something that like
we've been saying and the whole
Internet's been saying is like well they
they're setting Anakin up to be the
father you know Ahsoka to potentially be
the
daughter Ezra to be the Sun but I don't
think that's happening anymore I wonder
if maybe Bal fits that role um but I
think think what we've officially set
ourselves up for in kind of this like
this
overarching the force behind the force
is aith who is the mother and we only
ever saw aith in I think it was 2008
2009 uh the fate of the Jedi book series
which is like one of the last like
expanded universe pieces and she is like
like her title is like the bringer of
chaos or something to that effect um and
is one of the most like horrifying
horrific misbalances of the force and
presents an existential threat not just
to the Galaxy but to the Galaxy's plural
and to the force and and the balance of
it as a whole and uh this idea of like a
old gray Jedi who survived Order 66 who
is kind of done everything he can to get
to this galaxy to go on this Quest I'm
so excited to like I would just watch
Balin with no other characters go on
this journey and would be a happy happy
camper um but they you know this was an
arc
that one of the few that George Lucas
really gravitated towards and actually
adapted from the books into the Clone
Wars ARC and I'm sure Dave Fon had a
hand in that um but this to me seems
like I don't know what the treatments of
you know 78 and N uh were that George
Luc was dreaming up and had offered to
Disney uh but I've got a feeling the
wills I've got a feeling that we're
seeing it yeah um uh at least an extent
of it um you know it's it's well then
you also got James mangle's movie which
is supposed to be the like the is it the
origin of the Jedi or something the
origin of the Jedi which I think is the
perfect I I think we'll probably see
aith in her prime yeah um and maybe even
that whole I mean I'm so curious what
would be the most efficient ient way to
describe like the father son and
daughter they are the physical
representations of the balance of the
force yeah um and so the father being
the epitome of balance and keeping light
and darkness from consuming one another
and from one becoming too powerful yeah
the the mother is a factor that we
haven't seen and how that plays in and
in a way and this is what I'm really
really hoping
for Anakin's story could theoretically
continue as he takes on this role like
his his role of the chosen one to bring
balance of the force based on everything
that they've set up was for him to
become the father after the father died
in it's been a couple years since I've
seen that just
rewatched if I'm not if my memory serves
me correct didn't the father want Anakin
to take was it the son's place or his
place his place his place
he he wanted to see Theos one in to see
if it was true and when it when the
Reckoning came part of explaining to
Anakin that he was the chosen one was
showing him what he will become in the
form of Vader and that is
ultimately I think what what pushed him
away from it um but notice how in the
time that the father died the balance of
the force has since been completely off
right and now there is this opportunity
to remedy yet um but I I think that you
know so so like what what in the Clone
Wars dat when it was like ob1 uh Ahsoka
and Anakin were on an adventure then
they got pulled into it's just it's
called mortise they got pulled into
mortise and that's where they met them
on this like beautiful imagine like uh
Legend of Zelda and Nintendo
DS Lally
theor and uh and yeah they got the and
the and the sun was like uh his father
son daughter and like the way they're
this like ethereal way they're all drawn
and one of them has a big beard one of
them has a big beard has a big beard
which I saw carved in the stone that's
great catch that's great catch and the
sun kind of looks like a grand
Inquisitor like like the yeah it's from
do the kids represent chaos or or airing
toward one side of the spectrum or the
the daughter is the light the son is the
darkness and then Ahsoka died and
in this Arc and then was brought back to
life by the daughter okay res like
giving her giving her giving her life
force into her and and that bird that we
saw morai uh is a representation of that
and following her out but the question I
have is Ahsoka doesn't remember any of
that right if I'm not mistaken that's
right they don't remember any of that I
think the there is only bits and pieces
um did not think this would be the like
such a thing we were be talking about in
this episode well damn that's the ending
they set it up it's what they it's it's
playing into the and I I'm hopefully
what this origin of the Jedi movie will
be is getting into like like the crazy
like spirituality of the force and like
the idea of balance and light Darkness
felon's evolved in that Jedi movie I'm
hopefully hopefully well I think it has
to be I it would be a waste of of
they've they've made so many positive
strides in telling a cohesive narrative
um and and I think it's great it it
takes away some characters that we care
about and puts them in an arc that is
equally important in an entirely
different galaxy um and that has really
high stakes um well also like bringing
back Ezra and allowing us to like
continue I mean Ezra is going to be such
a great addition to the Mandalorian team
up you know and all that totally agree
but what is what how is
Balin like he want he keeps talking
about um obtaining a power power well
how how would he obtain a power from I
think in the same way that Anakin and
Ahsoka were brought to Morse Balin has
been summoned to this Galaxy and he has
been through the force aith who has been
literally like like if I'm remembering
correctly and it's been a while like she
was banished and locked away and kept
away like which is why we don't see her
in the mortise Arc crazy and so
this idea of you know the repres your
mother is insane woman represents
chaos they can't control Bal probably
thinks he is finding that balance when
in reality he is unleashing chaos uh and
I I think ultimately uh Balin is a
fascinating choice for the Son and the
because we never did get a replacement
for you know who's going to fill that
that void um and Anakin Ahsoka and Balin
I would just watch that I would just
watch them talk to each other about like
who how's the weather today I mean Force
ghost Anakin is a great thing to be
bringing into here because one thing
that excites me as like what what I
would would have informed of via the
comments you guys is that Hayden
Christian said didn't act he did
actually consume Clone Wars uh he he
went back and he watched all of it he
ate TVD well oh no I mean it because
that was one of the great things about
his performance was it it felt like it
was informed by all of the progress of
the yeah he was bringing the animated
performance to life it was a great
marriage of what he did in the prequels
and then what you see in the animated
shows and I so every time he's there I'm
like I love seeing him because he's he's
doing it he's doing it all he just seems
so happy to be here he does he does seem
happy to be here and with them being
stranded here with all the Jedi training
that could be taking place of course
with Ahsoka and Sabine we'll get some
present day interaction that is not so
much of an ethereal Wonderland of like
World Between Worlds but something more
AK to like when Luke interacts with
Obi-Wan's ghost or when Luke interacts
with Yoda oh was almost it it very
similar I mean even in timing of you
know in the Obi-Wan series it took that
entire experience for Obi-Wan to be able
to see Qui-Gon and to be able to commune
with him in the force and I think for
Ahsoka this is finally the not only has
she come to terms with him and and what
went wrong but she's also come to terms
with herself and where she wronged her
Padawan and uh I think that balance will
be really helpful for all of them um
yeah I'm just so curious because you
also have Shin which like that's just an
open-ended
fascinating where is she G to go like
there's there's I think there's still a
lot more there um she found her people
yeah but but that's whatever the hell's
going on there that's a temporary I rule
you now uh I mean same uh this is great
huh isn't this baren Wasteland awesome I
mean I hope it amounts to more than just
her being there to create fun scenes
next season we're going to kick these
naughties asses every day going to bully
going to go like this for centuries have
some Turtle suit uh perpetuate a cycle
of violence yeah I mean what's what's
next on our on our list here I mean we
were talking about Force ghost Anakin
which I'm very much excited about we
covered mortise um the one
morai uh I I guess I would like to talk
about Morgan elsabeth next that' be fun
what a great character great execution a
villain with motive that I believed an
actor that just I think knocked it out
of the park I think she brought more to
it than the writing brought to it h
thousand like I think the writing was
very like I there filon is one of those
writers like conceptually I think he is
a F genius conceptually speaking
and what he adds to Universe building is
phenomenal times though like his
dialogue is not the greatest you know
and sometimes his character development
is not the greatest uh in terms of how
to write certain sometimes it is really
great like he's written some of the best
Star Wars you will have ever seen all
right I I got to just say like he's
written some amazing Star Wars content
and then there are other times where it
does feel
I I don't he's get it feels like I'm
watching like a really neat outline and
uh sure and and and that's the part
where it can lack for me and I think
like you can see the right and Morgan
eleth is a case too where I felt like
there was so much more richness to mine
from her or or to really develop that I
was en I really enjoyed her presence
here and um I I actually like the reveal
of how Thon was just like yep go when I
need your out of her you don't really
matter to me like yeah but when she does
die it is a bummer to me a because I
thought there was more to really we
could have done with her and be you know
to have her set up in the
Mandalorian again like I really love the
writing of filoni's writing in that
episode I thought that was really great
yeah that's one of the strongest
episodes and he directed that one too
usually when he directs and writes it's
really strong um and and then uh it does
feel like we didn't really get get
enough out of her it was just she was
mainly here just giving information like
all all season it's just she's just
giving information she gave a main
supporting character performance to a
role written like a main Hench just like
you know she had a lot of presence and I
would have loved to have peered through
that character's perspective especially
being that she is being inducted
gradually into this hor of death
religion yeah yeah you know there's so
much that's interesting about that and
that expands just what this world deals
with I think all of this flirts with
going into the more Fantastical the more
spiritual the Le like Star Wars has all
that but I'm used to seeing the
technological sci-fi side of that where
I feel like through her you could have
rung some rich drama especially out of
what appeared in Lars mikkelson's
performance like a calculated move like
not not oh it's unfortunate but this is
what needs to be done it's sort of like
no Now's the Time for this move I
anticipated where I'm gonna sacrifice
you oh dude yes thanks for segueing us
John
Thon Michael Michael thon's thon's plan
Thon th wants to go to damir there there
wants to resurrect Darth
Maul for the
third there was a uh there was that one
line of protecting the Galaxy that I was
like oh I'm a treasure prot there there
she is what we've been building up
towards
um I it could go so many directions I
mean the obvious one is they're going to
resurrect whoever whether it be the
witches of damir or or more dead Storm
Troopers it could be a meta commentary
on rewriting the Star Wars Canyon so
that would practice against Kathleen
Kennedy that's exactly what it is sa the
Galaxy from Kathleen Kennedy I mean guys
right clickbait and Ryan Johnson I'm
excited to ever gonna get to that new
Trilogy yeah probably not um but uh you
know I I think we're looking at it a
head-to-head clash with the Imperial
Remnant and all that I just I hope they
don't waste thrawn on like joining up
with the emperor and the whole Sith
Eternal and all that I just like I'm it
doesn't do anything for me uh on a story
level and I think the far more
interesting situation would be for Thon
to get back for him to get all the
Imperial Remnant together and for them
to fraction off because he's like we
need to save the Galaxy from this
external threat and the other ones are
going on the The Witch Hunt to try to
find Palpatine uh which at at some point
like that needs to connect because some
of those folks end up going that route
there's great drama to ring out of a
situation like like I think that's a
Show's worth I don't think that's a
movie yeah honestly like I feel like a
movie might rush that well I part
of me wonders if we're
missing some of the shows that are gonna
be coming out this there there's a
waight to e like they got Ezra back and
and uh and and
and man I am just blinking on everyone's
names this episode that's fun no no Hera
God damn it so and
Hera um is right about Thon being a
threat and it's like but at what cost
was it to to be right and what Co like
what cost was it to bring back Ezra if
it led to Thon returning unless unless
th would have return unless the thon's
purpose is to protect the Galaxy from a
greater threat which I
continue from the grisk you or the yuzan
Vang depending on you know yeah what you
want to call them but you know I I think
that's an interesting setup for a um you
know you could also see like the
creation of the resistance you know this
idea of like part of why Leia created it
in the first place is because the new
Republic wasn't taking the Imperial
remnant seriously right um so you know
and then the question is like is Luke
getting involved like there's just I
have so many questions and no answers
but I think they need a thraw show in
order to properly tell that side of the
story I think it would just be nice if
if maybe bringing thrawn back to the
mess that is the new Republic and the
Imperial Remnant like I think it would
be a great opportunity for some
characters to survey all of that and go
like none of you are doing this right
right yeah like because one thing that
has aggravated me about a few of these
past series just how kind of thickheaded
the uh uh you know New Republic is in in
a maddening kind of unbelievably
cartoonish way it is maddening and
unbelievably cartoonish like I I
understand what they're getting at and
like yes like of course there's going to
be bureaucracy of course it's going to
be impossible to get a lot of things
done but like the sheer negligence of it
all is just like so frustrating yeah and
to have a character that like you know
supposed to be this very you know Wise
and learned and calculated tactician I
would hope like that just demands a
caliber of writing that the political
leanings of the series have not been
able to satisfy yeah Sabine Ren
character Arc she went from her want was
to save Ezra got it done her need was to
believe in herself and grow and become
the force sensitive badass that she is
and she is um I don't feel feel like her
Arc combined with writing and acting was
necessarily a grand slam for
me sure out when it needed to it feels
generous uh I mean in all fairness she
all season long she's been holding out
her freaking hand trying to use the
force and nothing's been happening yeah
no so it does come in at the nick nick
of time with an emotional up and and
she's like with Ezra there's and she's
feel like she's feeling good about
herself she's got more she's got better
things going on you know she just more
light energy yeah you know there better
more reasons to believe in herself in
this moment man it was satisfying uh but
the
the it's like it's all there like the
arc but it just there's something that
is like borderline flat to me about the
landing Point um other than some moments
that I thought really shined and uh I I
like a lot of her moments especially in
action
scenes uh however the there's a little
bit one note of a perform of of like
writing and acting combined it was flat
and I didn't want it to be flat I mean I
was really really rooting for her my
favorite character in the show next to
Kanan next to Rebels uh she's my favor I
was like what are you talking about
she's my favorite character in Rebels
mexic Canan and and that was a I think
of all the disappointments I felt like
they did such a great job um rera Dawson
in particular
evolved and
like the intentionality of the character
and how she was able to capture Ahsoka
yeah um really really hit you know and
like any reservations I had in the
beginning throughout the full season Arc
with it now in you know in retrospect uh
was perfectly executed whereas Sabine
there was surface level growth but I
honestly I just like there was never
chemistry where I wanted it to be and
there was like a little tiny bit with
Ezra but even that like I F like Ezra
was holding the entire weight of that
relationship um there was there's
questionable choices on on how to direct
her for certain scenes honestly like it
was just there was a lot of questionable
like yeah that she was yeah dialogue
didn't help and questionable decisions
about her like all the times where she's
like withholding information to Ezra and
a lot of it just kind of got chocked up
to uh her like smiling and like pretend
like like mirroring ahsoka's mannerisms
of
confidence I I understand you know like
I've I've produced and worked on enough
things to know like sometimes when
you're in the middle of it you realize
that you might have made some wrong
choices and I I think the frustrating
part is like continue for a long time to
give the benefit of the doubt that
lessons would be learned and that they
would make those slight adjustments to
RP the season and I liked her a lot in
the beginning well I I loved her in the
first episode uh which yeah remember the
first episode I was like wow this is
great and then it was just a steady
decline honestly from the moment her and
Ahsoka teamed up which really again
leads me to think it was a chemistry
issue I liked her a lot in
137 no when did she find Ezra six six 13
six yeah I like her L but even in it was
like it was good but it wasn't great
remember it wasn't I never yeah I've
never been like strongly drawn to her
and and that's a bummer whereas like I
know Rosario Dawson at first was like
there's some things I'm not fully
getting and then eventually like I
really get that was that was a that was
a performance choice that needed to
like there was a reason for it and then
they explain the reason and then her
character evolved with that Arc and
since then I like I've been just vibing
with Ahsoka like I am bum we did not get
to see them meet in person thraw and
Ahsoka we we will um we will yeah we
will we will uh I like that Ezra got a
new
lightsaber which inspired by Kanan I
thought was just awesome I did not there
were so many people up in arms about the
lightsaber thing of last week yeah about
him not using his lightsaber like people
were like up in arms about it well I
mean it it and I was like what it makes
sense like a guy is going to honestly
the fact that he built the lightsaber at
all I thought was like well that's it's
remarkably practical especially after
being gone for so long yeah he also like
if if you know the character of Ezra
he's like he loves to Tinker and build
like of course he wasn't going to take
back the lightsaber he was going to do
his own thing CU that's always been Ezra
this is this is his third light saber no
goes through them like a Michael goes
through women that's right man
jeez use the force oh no I mean no no
terrible terrible politely obtain the
consent Luke do or do not there is no
try yes or no God damn guys um man
that's disgus this is the show I would
say has a better a better Ensemble than
it does individual characters we need
chemistry we need well aside from a
couple
darkers has chemistry with everything I
thought like air I thought a sooka and
huyang had better chemistry than Ahsoka
and Sabine yes um has chemistry with
everyone hang has chemistry with
everyone Balin and shin were great yeah
um the the last thing we got to talk
about night
Troopers this is something I've been
waiting for from the comics forever like
and like I I think they needed to be
reserved about it in the best way that
they
like I don't know I think they found a
balance that scene was very clunky but
I'll tell you what I think the reason
why is they cut 10 minutes off that way
you have to do less
editing these reactors got to get their
up man people doing Break episod um
yeah I mean other than I I guess what we
need what we they really need was other
than the fact that they can be
resurrected is like like when you got
zombie horde coming after you the
fearers are going to bite you
you know so and here we need to
establish something like it needs to be
crystal sure what makes it more
threatening yeah because it seems like
you can still just like strike them down
it just seems like they're more
persistent in that state it's like
they're more durable there there's no
like what what I noticed and what gave
like me tension in the moment maybe it
didn't come across to you guys is that
they no longer feared death and so there
was this like
willingness Troopers Troopers ever like
oh my God they got a lightsaber I got to
get out here there's a when I say fear
death I mean there was an element of
strategy whereas these guys were just
like get close and I don't care how
brutal I die but some of them get close
with like no weapon and I'm like what's
there to fear about that well they got
to they could use their helmet to B Bash
they might bite me and it might hurt
they might try to bite me through their
mask listen if a stormtrooper can hold
them down long enough maybe one of them
can get a straight shot for once like
you know I don't
know yeah I but I did like it when
they're in a hoorde when they are I I
when it is a swarm and you're an
individual it's that's when it's like
scary it's the irony of like cuz they
charge yeah it's it made them scarier
only I think for that sake because I
think you're absolutely right like
logically speaking unless there's a
zombie virus to transmit what is the
threat here except for the fact that
yeah they can just hoard and and just
encroach and well that's what it is in
the expanded universe which is why I'm
saying like I'm grateful for what we got
because I never thought we were going to
get zombie Storm Troopers period and
they capture that well when when the
face breaks off and you have the and
then when you also have like Ahsoka
trying to fight out Morgan Elizabeth and
dealing with all that uh that conclave
of all that yeah that was kind of Army
of Darkness or something it felt kind of
like you had like a bunch of yeah pure
samam well there was a bit of that like
kind of slight Camp to it at least and
you're in like a castle you know like so
my thumbnail is going to be a Anakin
Force ghost I think that won't upset
people smiling we um we're gonna need
that'll put the troll face on his face
and then I'll split screen it with the
night I love it I love it uh I'm and
then the text will say Thon
wins Emperor Thon thrown I think the
Galaxy would be better off sounds like
true seems like all right guys what did
you think about the Ahsoka finale did
you love it did you hate it do you got
to have it do you like it have you been
to menes which frozen yogurt joint do
you prefer Yogurt Land men what's your
preferred topping are we talking are you
like a cookie dough Eminem like a p
sizes how would you rate this episode
have you had vegan ice cream leave your
thoughts Down Below guys um hey thanks
for having me on for this Greg will I be
ever back yeah of course man we got um
nothing for a long time strikes this is
this is a Star Wars season 3 oh no tales
of the Jedi season 2 God tals of oh
that's right pass the Christ the
resurrection we already watched Tales of
Jedi season chist no he didn't no that
was
Visions dumb ass tell Jedi season two
the origin story is a b the origin story
is a Balin um uh who are they who are
they going to recast oh my god oh dude
alen richson
I like it from Jack Reacher guys I'm
here for it I um get Ray Winstone does
he have a brother who Ray Stevenson I
think it does Ray there a lot of Stevens
yeah Ray winst his brother us should
Ray's the
surname yeah they're Korean secretly
sometimes they reorder the names no
wonder it's the only good acting in Star
Wars because it's Korean Stevenson Ray
and Winstone Ray hey let's do a patron
of the day shout out oh I love patrons
there's a chat GPT oh John wants to do
the chat gbt that's right like a kid at
the candy store got it said there's a
chat gvt window open for you know how we
do here at the chel out said there chat
gvt right there there's people striking
right now trying to end the rider strike
is done we can make fun of chat GB yeah
but the actors well what they're not
going to act with Chad gbt we got this
we
time all right Lance door we're going to
give you a Star Wars edition shout out
all right Michael give me an article of
clothing Star Wars edition oo uh Leia's
bikini Leia's
bikini okay John give me a Star Wars or
Hut Slayer I think is what the official
merchandise is these days okay Hut
Slayer and then um John give me a planet
CU I know you can f that um uh uh deoa
oh nice
deoa and um give me a how do you spell
Deo you spelled hot hot I thought you
said I spelled it wrong you did there's
two t Jesus Christ oh my God all right
we got I got limited time here daaba the
chat supposed to speed up the
proc okay okay all right okay give me uh
your favorite Jedi my favorite Jedi oh
my God just give me a Jedi AB ABW Kenobi
OB Obi-Wan Kenobi Obi-Wan Kenobi John
give me um a your favorite Star Wars
character non-jedi Dash renar Dash renar
Okay and um all right give me a a ship a
ship uh the eban Hawk eban Hawk did I
spell it right sure did Evan Hawk all
right give me your favorite actor in
Star Wars o uh uh Liam niss Liam niss
okay all right give me your favorite
Disney Plus show from Star Wars my
favorite disne oh we're going
Mandalorian no no we're oh my God we're
going bad batch season we're going the
bad batch bch season two the bad batch
best Star Wars content ever made okay
all right we're going and then um lastly
an obscure occupation in the Galaxy an
obsc
uh a a uh uh uh bantha
fodder cleaner upper cleaner upper oh
last one um let's put Chopper in here as
a Droid Chopper sure yeah okay as a
model I have a YouTube channel where I
need to shout out my super sexy reject
AKA a patron named Lance door we want to
give him a Star Wars them themed shout
out write me a shout
out uh that is let's go with let's up
the game here that is 70 words woo oh
that's a lot of words make sure to
incorporate I feel like we included more
than 70 words we certainly did
incorporate these words into it all
right and let's uh change it to uh 50
words
a
lot oh here take it away in a Galaxy
where Leia's bikini Hut Slayer uh Reigns
Supreme on the froggy planets of deoa
Heroes like Obi-Wan Kenobi and dash
renar fly the ibben hawk but only one
legend lanceor mentored by leam out
shines the bad batch not just a bantha f
cleaner upper he's our Chopper level
Patron shout out to you oh my God it is
replacing screenwriters everywhere that
was so genus uh so if you had a choice
to write a new sequel Trilogy Dave filon
or
chbt um chat gbt well there you have it
chat GPT with a cowboy rewrite the
sequel Trilogy for me in 30 words oh
actually Jesus let's see what they say
oh Jesus no Legacy threatened ancient
Sith Secrets emerge Ray discovers
lineage challenges Destiny Finn Sparks
Stormtrooper Revolt kylo seeks
Redemption Force ghosts guide Galaxy
unites balance restored
like this is the best tool oh man it it
it read it got a Reddit posted it was
just like here we go thank you guys
thank you Lance door I got to get this
video to you got see you
soon
[Music]